welcome back to las vegas now you know
as people get older arthritis can sneak
in and really affect your joint function
i spoke to a southwest medical doctor
about the proper treatments to keep your
joints feeling and moving
their best take a look just start with
the basics of what arthritis is and how
it affects the body
sure arthritis is inflammation
of the joints really the end stage of
arthritis is once that cartilage is
completely worn away
as a result of the inflammation or the
trump or the trauma
but as a result of the inflammation
causing bone to rub up against
bone probably the simplest way that i
can explain it
but it can affect any joint um in the
body anywhere where two bones come
together
it is a source where arthritis can
attack
my knees my knees are hurting just
listening to that
so it is very common knee arthritis is
very common yeah
um the hip arthritis is common the
weight-bearing joints it's probably more
common in the
in the joints that bear weight we walk
on those
right right and what about age does it
matter
certainly age-related we see uh higher
rates of arthritis symptomatic arthritis
in the older population for sure
absolutely so what are the medications
or therapies that people should
should look into if they're having
arthritis so looking at uh
anything that can decrease inflammation
uh could probably help
make the joints feel better now there's
you know there's multiple uh
non-steroidal anti-inflammatory
medications that
uh things like ibuprofen aleve
um prescription those are
over-the-counter examples
um there's a there are topical
anti-inflammatory medications that
are now available over the counter like
voltaire and gel
then there's prescription
anti-inflammatory medications like
for example celebrex or meloxicam
endomethacin there's a whole range of
medications that that we can choose from
in the non-steroidal anti-inflammatory
medication class
other than that there are certain um uh
keeping
the your weight under control
you know obesity definitely increases
the amount of inflammation in the body
which in and of itself can cause joints
to hurt
um and then there's certain foods that
are pro-inflammatory
there there's certain supplements that
are anti-inflammatory so i think diet
and lifestyle is also a big part of a
joint health
and decreasing the chances of having
symptomatic and painful arthritis
also surgery is an option what are those
options
joint replacement is where we resurface
the end of the joint
we put a new surface on where the
cartilage is worn away
and those procedures in the hip and the
knee can be
life-changing and i see
multiple extremely happy patients every
time i'm in clinic that have undergone
these procedures
and um they're full of gratitude they
feel like they've got their life back
so when they're done in the right person
at the right time they're incredibly
effective and
incredibly valuable there's definitely
things that the patients can do to
improve their outcomes and there's
things that we can do as surgeons to
improve outcomes it's definitely a
partnership
you can find optum care orthopedic and
spine on west oaky boulevard for more
information just call 702-724-8877